una nueva cepa del corona virus
identificada en reinounido es la razón
para que el primer ministro británico
haya decidido restringir aún más los
encuentros sociales de fin de año de
acuerdo con el equipo científico que
asesora al gobierno la nueva variante
del virus es hasta un 70% más infecciosa
que la anterior pero no se llega a
concluir que sea más mortal ni que las
vacunas dejen de ser efectivas ante la
noticia la organización mundial de la
salud responde en twitter estamos en
estrecho contacto con funcionarios del
reino unido- y respecto a la nueva
variante del virus de kobe 19
continuarán compartiendo información y
resultados de sus análisis y estudios en
curso actualizaremos a los estados
miembros y al público a medida que
obtengamos más información sobre las
características de esta variante del
virus y sus implicaciones
la restricción que cobija el sureste y
este de inglaterra y la ciudad de
londres implica el cierre del comercio
no esencial también los bares
restaurantes museos y queda prohibido
entrar o salir de las zonas que ahora
son nivel 4 de gravedad las reacciones
no se hicieron esperar en la oposición
las tasas de infección están aumentando
muy muy rápido por lo que hay que hacer
algo y apoyamos las medidas que ha
puesto en marcha el gobierno pero
millones de familias en todo el país
estarán desconsoladas por esta noticia
sus planes navideños se arruinaron
además decenas de personas salieron a
manifestar en contra de las
restricciones que afectan a millones de
personas que para esta navidad no podrán
reunirse con quienes no hagan parte de
su núcleo familiar reino unido- es la
región de europa más duramente castigada
por la pandemia junto a italia con más
de 67 mil fallecidos este sábado se
superó el umbral de 2 millones de casos
positivos